hi in this video we'll talk about
cofactors and coenzymes and we would
break these two term we all know that
enzymes which is having a catalytic
activity is totally dependent upon its
structural integrity and protein has
complex 3d structure right and let's say
there is a changing dramatic change in
pH or dramatic changing temperature it
might lead to teenager Asian of its
tertiary s tertiary structure and as a
result there could be a disruption of
the activity or the alteration of the
activity some enzymes don't need any
additional help from anything its
tertiary protein structure and how it is
folded is everything which determines
its catalytic activity and it's
sufficient for its optimum function but
some cases some enzyme need some
additional factors for its optimal
activity now these additional factors
which governs the optimum enzyme
activity is known as cofactors very
simple cofactors it's like a helping
hand you can imagine now these cofactors
of these enzymes could be of different
kind of species either these cofactors
could be metal ions like ferrous ion
manganese ion magnesium or zinc etc or
these cofactors could be relatively
complex organ metallic compounds or
complex organic groups which are known
as coenzymes so here we can clearly like
delineate two different species of
cofactors one is relatively simple like
metal ions and one is relatively complex
which are like organic groups or organic
compounds which we term as coenzymes let
us look at the metallic ions how they
serve as cofactors and do they have any
role in terms of enzymatic activity
modulation or catalysis it turns out
they have important function let us take
an example from RNA polymerase
we generally scans the DNA and
transcribe our DNA right then what
happens is in the catalytic site of
these DNA polymerase there are magnesium
ions these magnesium ions being a bi
valent cut down they help in the
transcription activity and they help in
the elongation of the growing RNA chain
there are two magnesium ions one helping
deprotonation of the three prime
hydroxyl group and the second magnesium
ion help to stabilize the transition
state and it helps to stabilize or
neutralize the negative charge on the
phosphate backbone that is how these
magnesium groups in the RNA polymerase
or any kind of DNA or RNA polymers help
in its catalysis okay now we understand
how these metallic ions can serve as a
cofactors let's talk about some complex
organic group which can serve as a
coenzyme right remember coenzyme is is
one type of cofactor one version of it
now let's consider a metabolism of
pyruvate where pyruvate gets converted
to acetaldehyde with that enzyme
pyruvate decarboxylase and further it
would be converted to ethanol by alcohol
dehydrogenase we only consider
concentrated about the first part and
the mechanism of action of pyruvate
decarboxylase pyruvate decarboxylase has
its cofactor which is timing pyro
phosphatase timing pyrophosphate is you
can see it's a complex organic group so
this kind of cofactor by nature it could
be termed as a coenzyme right now this
time in pyro phosphatase is actually
derived from the vitamin timing or
vitamin b1 which is normally available
form lean meat fried potato cereals milk
etc now these timing pyrophosphate
what it does is it works like a
acetaldehyde carrier
whenever the pyruvate is interacting
with these enzyme having time in pyro
phosphatase as a coenzyme it ultimately
interact with the Tyrolean ring and it
forms our active acetaldehyde complex
with the enzyme and which would be
ultimately released to form the
acetaldehyde but the question is how the
enzyme can help how the coenzymes can
help in catalysis so let us look at it
in a bit more details so here is
pyruvate decarboxylase as you can
understand from the name decarboxylation
reaction would be triggered by this
enzyme so here is our substrate pyruvate
now you can understand the pyruvate is
two carbon substrate a three carbon
substrate right now these pyruvate would
be initially forming a complex with
these timing pyro phosphatase like this
eventually this carbon dioxide would be
leaving this moiety now the carbon
dioxide is free so hence a step down
reaction or decarboxylation reaction is
triggered and in this situation these
these timing peroxidase is helping the
TUC timing pyrophosphate is helping
right which is a coenzyme of this enzyme
now eventually it would form an
intermediate called hydroxy tile time in
pyro phosphatase which would eventually
give rise to acetaldehyde and
acetaldehyde would be released and
further acetaldehyde would be acted upon
alcohol dehydrogenase to form ethanol
now thereby we understand in this video
that how metal ions can serve as
cofactors and help in catalysis and we
took an example of magnesium which is an
important cofactor for the RNA
polymerase we also took an example of an
complex organ a metallic group
which is our timing pyro phosphatase
which is derived from vitamin b1 and
looked at how it helps in catalysis so I
hope this video was helpful and it was
informative if you like this video give
a thumbs up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you